[Music]
okay welcome everybody we're gonna start
the strategy class and we will take a
look at one of my games played in
actually the first u.s. championship
organized here in st. Louis in 2009 that
was the first one here and I actually
had a really good run in that tournament
I was leading it again it seems like I
always managed to lead but can never
finish it you know I mean the best
finish was second place in 2014 but this
one also I started you know with five
out of four first place and then at the
very end I stumbled against the Cara
Nakamura where I was very close you know
to finally get my first title so but
this I had a good series in this
tournament I defeated some really good
players and some really good games so
this is one of them I want to share with
you and this is a game against
grandmaster julio Becerra
strong grandmaster originally from Cuba
but lives in United States for many
years now and Julio is 2610 Adam at the
moment 2609 his video ratings so very
very tough opponent so I play d4 he
played d5 c4 c6 and now and now we have
the Slav defense but I sometimes play
the exchange variation I didn't want to
do that here so I played e3 he faced a
six-night f3 and now so we have after
his 6 we have semi Slav defense ok as
soon as he plays Isaac so we know it's a
semi Slav so I had some good preparation
for this game my preparation I was
managing to catch people and I had a
good friend of mine my second at that
time Gabrielle sarkeesian he was my
second and helpers with the preparation
and we were catching some people you
know we cut Robson in a good preparation
I want julio Becerra I had the other
wins beat Joel Benjamin that
tournament first round a bit Donsky on
acetone ski so so he takes here normally
they wait until you move the bishop and
then they take okay they don't want to
take immediately because you will take
on c4 into in one move okay so you go
here
take take b5 attacking the bishop yeah I
mean the most important thing I want to
do guys I want to counsel
so I don't mind if I have to lose a
temple because he has to lose the
temperature because he's making a to
pawn moves in a row so so I wouldn't
worry about that too much you know
because he has to waste the temple
problem so Bishop d3 he takes I take b5
attacking the bishop
Bishop to e2
it should be seven okay here I have
another option is Bishop d3
Bishop b3 I think I played once it's a
very rare move here but Bishop e2 is the
most of natural a castle Castle Rock d1
rock d1 comes in and the point of the
move rogue d1 is here I would like to
prevent him from playing c5 or
preventing from he five
okay so because Grand Master Becerra my
opponent wants to play e5 or c5 here so
I would like to prevent that by doing
this move rock d1 okay
now this way it's gonna be harder for
him to do that because his queen is on
d8 okay so his queen is on the 8th is
difficult so he played Queen c7 and now
I play the move d4 he forced he for the
threat is to play e5 e for the threat is
to play a 5 and to attack attack the
bishop and attacked or a knight
now he played
'if I've putting pressure
I played if I put impression now I play
the move Bishop g5 okay at that point
the theory was you know to play h3 g3
sometimes take on e5
so this is kind of a new idea so Bishop
g5 now my opponent takes I have to
capture back here
I cannot capture back with a night
because I'm dropping the pawn on h2 so I
have to take back with a rook and now he
pushes on me again with p4 and here
we're novelty where my novelty comes in
here the next one was a novelty that
never played before and this is where my
friend Gabriel sarkeesian helped me with
the preparation okay this is where he
helped him with the preparation why to
play can you find that novelty that we
did in this game what did I play here to
get some kind of attack and initiative
against my opponent
Knight to d5 I don't know if it's gonna
work no Knight to d5 because he can take
back the Queen is protected yeah yeah
what did I play here you know initiative
tempos right so you want to try to make
a move that is gonna allow you to get
the initiative I can't move the knight
but then you know I'm losing the
initiative Michael excellent and rook a
d1 doubling up the rooks in attacking
the tax code Bishop but this is concrete
okay
of course you played Bishop c5 and now
suddenly looks like we are in trouble
the rook is under attack Knight is under
attack I'm losing material what to do
here but again this is where you know
you start using the computers to find
some ideas that your opponent probably
wouldn't expect so this is the line the
line continues here
what is the computer recommendation here
which I play it of course one is the
computer recommendation what did I play
here my knight is on Priya my rook is on
Priya what did I just do what did I just
do here got myself in trouble but it's
very interesting when you analyze you
know computer tells you think that you
wouldn't think about it
so this analysis you know very important
this analysis yes
any ideas
what did I play here if I move the night
he just takes my rocks oh yes 95 it
takes yeah no match for 94 is a
possibility but I'm not I'm not quite
sure the movie is unexpected
yeah this is the next move is unexpected
you're not expecting that you're gonna
do that okay but it's gonna lead to a
good position so ID is correct but I
sacrifice on d7 exchange purely
positional now he takes back and now
Michael absolutely
okay he cannot go back here because we
take and if it was only six some
consequences here you know because he's
got two pieces hanging this is the
problem all right so he went Bishop e6
as expected
yes
I'll take on this X take on this seven I
take two pieces yeah you don't want two
pieces on the same file because if I
already have a look on it I'll have more
pressure okay now what can you do here
what is the continuation because this is
still my analysis very important move to
gain some tempies activate pieces what
do you think
yes of course Bishop e7 Bishop wants to
go to d6 that other Bishop goes to C for
putting pressure on f7 with lots of
ideas so I was expecting rook e8 like
that computer line was through key eight
Bishop d6 Quincy eight Bishop c4 and
some very dangerous ideas coming up you
know some very dangerous potential
sacrifice on f7 so he didn't want to
deal with this in fact I think the line
is like this Bishop here it leads to
check it's like some kind of knight it's
just made basically and you just made
him Queen f3 and so he didn't want to do
that and he realized the danger
Grandmaster Becerra so he went back 95
he says you can have that exchange I
want to stop the dangerous initiative
just you know maybe slightly worse
position but get that so now I play B
should be sick because I want to force
him to take on f3 which he did I take
back now he goes there with Quinn the
next thing is here if I take this pawn
he's gonna get to look into the game
that's not gonna work very well so at
this point what should I do
Bishop takes f8 excellent he takes and
now no material is equal now look t7
here but he can play Bishop c8 or maybe
it'll p8 something better it's very
important to get the bishop into the
game here okay
absolutely ugly five getting space and
getting my bishop open now how is he
gonna move a bishop he can't so he goes
here up d8 proposing the exchange of the
Brooks now what should I do here huh
well don't rush don't rush
it's a busy background problem there is
lots of problems I don't think you can I
don't think you can afford I don't think
you can afford to die right now
not yet but he also his two bishops you
know and this is that is excellent
thinking of course Knight takes bishop
you eliminate the bishop so he doesn't
have the advantage of the other pair of
the bishops okay
he's got no advantage of the pair of the
bishops now he takes back and now very
important move here needed the reason we
cannot take on c6 because we have what
kind of problems rook takes the one we
have what problem we have background
right so how we resolve the patron
problem age 300 g3 actually because even
though he has a light square bishop here
g3 is okay because his bishop never
gonna really threaten that because I'm
controlling the diagonal so jittery is a
little bit more important because at
some point I want to cover the f4 square
as well he took I took Queen e7
now 26 are you sure because you can take
take and play King f8 and you might be
you might be I don't know a little bit
of trouble there you know I might lose
that pawn so but idea is good actually
you just have to do the proper proper
execution okay the proper execution
needed here Queen b3 I like to defile it
now because aha
Queen d4 correct move attacking the pawn
it seems that but wait a minute we were
blundering something with c5 no he
attacks the Queen now suddenly and the
bishop is on prey and nothing
immediately we can find here right but
now we go back Michael to your original
line Queen d6 proposing the exchange he
captured we capture now if he takes how
is he gonna stop this pawn he can't so
that's why he cannot do that and if he
goes here now what do we do very quickly
you have to do this the shop c6 yes er
covers it d7 winning a piece and the
game as well so this Queen before is
actually very important move without
this I think I've got an advantage here
actually because I've got an advantage
because he doesn't have a love Tina that
lift is very important okay that lift is
very very important
so he goes here b5 and that's what we
want to force him to play b5 who else he
could have done if he had gone here I
would just take on before you know so
it's bad well O'Quinn a Sonia so he went
here b5 Queen a7 by Michael excellent
threat is to go here word and to take as
well absolutely
so it was Queen to c7 Queen to c7 now
very important move needed here don't do
this because I was thinking about this
wow this is brilliant I take bishop
takes I take the Queen and if he takes I
have this oops he defends trouble no
good but now we can establish a blockade
right then you know very important is to
know how to establish a blockade look at
that okay now look at the bishop on b7
simply buried yeah buried behind his
palm here he can never I'm not gonna let
him play c5 here and let's our winning
some serious material
so he goes g6 see that okay I mean you
take me I take you know it's not gonna
be dubbed bigger a problem now Kendrick
to prophylactic you improve the position
we're not in hurry to do anything in g7
a little bit more pressure
threatening some h5 ideas let's see what
he will do
h5 he stops it but that stretches the
position a little bit now
b3 fixing it fixing it he goes he's got
no moose he's in sook cirhonk that's why
he was buffet
Bishop ate he's got no moves here now
sook now what do you do here there's a
possibility that is a possibility
Bishop e2 what else I want to actually
sacrifice the e pawn instead of giving
you for free because I gotta take on
before and I want to loosen his position
okay d6 no because if I take the pawn he
takes me so let's loosen him up and then
we take it and look at the position is
very stretched out and he still got
bunch of weaknesses here yeah so it was
Queen a7 trying to play c5 and now check
now this is the moment here this is the
moment you know he's threatening to play
c5 are we gonna let that happen
absolutely not you can't go Queen e5 but
he'll he might still play c5 now how are
you gonna stop c5 how are you gonna
prevent him from getting out of it huh
before excellent more more participation
more participation excellent fixing it
yeah he takes the pawn no problem
Michael
don't worry about the pawns let's go for
the attack here now that King seems very
weak No very very weak Queen f6 let's
get closer to his position here and
after Bishop before I think there could
be some serious consequences and he
cannot just move this guy here now why
is this move losing who can show me
quickly the winning idea
thank you thank you very much okay so he
goes back here queen a7 to the defense
and now what you're gonna do to put more
pressure on the weakness more pressure
on the weakness on g6 absolutely
remember the movie six there is a reason
why we 36 there is a reason why we
played h4 h5 to stretch the position so
now we have a target so he plays Queen
g7 barely barely hanging on
now what do you do next of course no
it's really stuck here
he cannot place c5 g6 is saying so it
goes Bishop e7 at some point you have to
watch out for for a bailout c5 idea okay
some bailout c5 idea now what do you
think I should do here is this the time
to break through
Bishop c6 Michael you giving you're
giving some advantage away you know he's
gonna he's gonna fight here this is no
clear-cut victory I could win the pawn
but it's gonna be a lot of work to win
this position with us that's exactly
what I played another excellent move by
you perfect
g4 yeah now the threat is to take it up
yeah well if he takes as you mentioned
the winning move winning touch is h5 if
he goes here look at that oh he's gonna
find a winning move here nice winning
move should be seven he takes Queen be
seven he checks you Michael you pinned
there you go Queen g6 check if it takes
if it goes back with trade Queens if it
takes we take check thank you very much
winning the piece so he cannot take
because h5 just wins the game h5 so he
goes King h6 and now what do I do here
g5 is very tempting right g5 is very
tempting but what else what else can you
do here
simpler let's expose the position of
that King so he takes you now he is also
eyeing to take my pawn on h4 potentially
change e3 maybe some Queen c7 checks or
something something better we have here
well f3 yes f3 because if he takes the
pawn we have queen g4 mate you see that
and now we threaten check he goes back
check he goes back
so we threaten now check check and h5 so
he goes Queen age 6
he sees the threat he wants to go away
from the threat
he's he gonna accomplish that what did I
play here huh
absolutely Michael h5 now pong cannot
take it spin soap Queen has to take I go
check if he takes we have check check
check mate check
Kinji three of course safety no checks
mate is still threatened he goes back
well you're not gonna defend the
position by doing that because now let's
collect some more material and now we've
got nice sorry we have a threat of check
and mate check and mate
so he goes here check
well just just go ahead for ya he goes
Bishop c8 hoping to I don't know
attacking me well again I mean there's a
little hope here you put the King on a
wrong square he goes Bishop c8 you know
you get pity not sir of course I wasn't
gonna dead now and the final move of
this game after which my opponent will
don't rush don't rush don't rush don't
worry about winning pawns let's finish
the game in style with a mate it made in
few moves
g7 no need to suck them no need to
sacrifice anything okay no need to
sacrifice anything right now there is no
need for you to do that absolutely Queen
f6 now you're threatening Czech Queen
eight seven eight you threaten g7 mate
ideas so he cannot do anything and if he
blocks it with this checkmate here okay
and after Queen f6 my opponent resigned
so this was the win in the 20 2009 US
Championship against remastered Becerra
so if you play this opening you you'll
know what to do now against the same is
life I like to go over the back it up to
the beginning to opening moves just to
make sure you remember the opening part
okay so so it started off with c4 c4 c6
what is why play Knight c3 first and
then III so now the Slav became semi
Slav okay Knight f3 Knight bTW servant
Quincy to Bishop d6 trip here
drop back
efore 35 he plays 'if I've and now this
is where my idea came Bishop g5 taking
with the rook and then following it up
okay and this creative sacrifice that
led to an advantage
okay here's rook e8 he didn't play
located because he was you know because
I was just all it's all preparation here
very dangerous for him so he don't want
that so he played 95 and this was
slightly worse after each fight okay so
again you can find this game online very
easily if you want spend a little bit
more time go a little bit slower but I
quite like this game I think it was a
very strong positional game in my
opinion now we will do some positions
okay so I will set up some positions for
you to work on and the topic I want to
continue working on it's a little bit
I've been doing the last couple of
lectures is the silent move silent move
topic okay where you find a silent idea
and suddenly you winning the game okay
2013 World Cup tournament and a playoffs
against my master Corey from Peru and
against a very high rank crime master
2,700 Teemu raja baath raja baath vs
Corey
white to play white to play and win
don't rush because you think it's easy
you might be missing something
because you got some serious background
problems here so the topic is silent
move which is basically a quiet move you
make or you're looking for a similar
idea to be able to get a winning
position just think to see there's a
background problems there is some look
look a five idea look at five would be
five ideas so there's some problems
which are Queen a one
aha very interesting silent move yet
Queen a1 the bishop takes now
threatening this and a background is
protected so you have two ideas now
you're threatening to take this and on
top of that who can tell me the second
threat the white is threatening to do
here that is that is excellent rf1
absolutely pouring pressure and getting
the advantage got it
that's a good move all right yeah and
just game over on the spot you'd only
have to not to worry about anything else
yes it guards the background so no
background issues okay and now
threatening to take the rook and sets up
a quiet look everyone move as well
got it perfect all right excellent work
that's a good one very very good one now
white to play and win this is the game
Alma she gramma said al ma she 2700
Grandmaster bruisin played in capablanca
memoria a couple of years ago in Cuba
and what do you think here this rooks
the the black rooks they look a little
bit funky yeah they look like they're a
little bit misplaced oh by the way
Grandmaster Alma she missed this he
played like a Knight f3 move which is
strange and that allowed the move c5 in
black actually complicated but now you
have a way to win this game you have a
way to simply win this game and it just
takes a couple of moves to do that
that's what he played that's what ala ma
she did but but an se5 is very strong so
he played 93 but after you know he wants
to go 94 but after this it's it's not a
big big I mean you might be a little bit
better about it you're not gonna win
look a d1 B where and the species here
yeah I know you want to play c4 huh
okay thinking correctly thinking
correctly we need to a place before we
want to play c4 but the problem is with
dropping the b-pawn and that's a little
problem there yeah okay for Bishop C -
Michael uncle is correct yes so there a
problem there as well huh but then your
knight drops because I have two
attackers on your night but that rook on
a7 is very funky - okay yeah the rukon
a7 is very
well not immediately not immediately
that would have been a piece of cake 96
yeah but not immediately but you're
thinking it correctly that's you guys
have to correct ideas see 4096 but how
are you gonna make it work
if you make it work that's it you just
have to figure out a way to make it work
aha immediately but immediately you drop
tonight so maybe have to do something
first you have to do something first
okay you do something first huh no
explicit takes back with a sip and then
the Rope comes in so you gotta you gotta
look at this - funky rocks here and do
something about these two looks you give
him a pause he's gonna get back into the
game okay you don't want to give a pass
pause okay here you cannot give a pause
hmm that's a pause
that's a pause you're not threatening
anything with that okay we want to
improve the Queen to play nice easy cry
but we keep running at this rook takes
e5 problem how about we sacrifice a pawn
to shift that look to move that look
from b5 correct
sacrifice a pawn he can if takes we just
take he has to take right now and c6 but
he takes to the Queen so that wasn't one
so you do something to set up and c6 you
do something now to set up 96 and we had
that move mentioned earlier correct
correct
look at that now 96 is coming how is he
going to prevent that so he takes the
best line is to take 96 attacking the
rook now he goes to b7 and now don't
settle for this because you might not
win this so easily
don't settle for that win a piece how
you
win a piece and then take on a five that
wins a piece quite a difficult one let's
give you a little bit of a hard time it
was difficult one
for sure and 2,700 2,700 grandmaster
didn't see it you know don't feel too
bad you didn't see it either but that's
why that's why you were doing this so
you look at this kind of ideas that's
the thing you don't stop because it's
difficult you do it because you want to
learn this ideas see for hitting the
rock temporarily temporarily pawn
sacrifice he takes and show me the
silent move that's it and now that wins
the game right there for you okay
that is the silent move excellent okay
okay
all right guys silent moves remember
okay it's a good topic for you this is
excellent everybody did a good job today
and we'll see you next time okay
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]